ahora veamos cómo trabajar con un
problema de un lanzamiento horizontal de
proyectil si ustedes ya saben cómo hacer
problemas de lanzamiento de proyectiles
aquí no habría nada nuevo excepto que
hay un aspecto de este tipo de problemas
con el que las personas siempre se
equivocan les voy a indicar cuáles en un
momento para que ustedes no se
equivoquen en esto a qué nos referimos
con un lanzamiento horizontal de
proyectil pues es sobre cualquier objeto
que sea lanzado de inicio con una
dirección horizontal digamos que esto lo
estamos lanzando de un precipicio en una
dirección completamente horizontal sin
ningún componente vertical si esto es
desde el inicio entonces tendremos un
lanzamiento horizontal del proyectil
qué podría hacer esto pues podría ser
una pelota que se está moviendo sobre
una mesa por ejemplo esta pelota va
rodando encima de la mesa y la velocidad
de inicio que tiene esta pelota si la
mesa es plana y horizontal la velocidad
inicial de esta pelota va a ser
horizontal así que si la velocidad
inicial del proyectil es completamente
horizontal entonces tendremos un
proyectil lanzado horizontalmente y
debido a que las personas muchas veces
hacen cosas locas digamos que esta
persona va a lanzarse de este precipicio
y pueden decir muy bien voy a hacer esto
aquí voy va a ir corriendo corriendo
corriendo pero no va a saltar del
precipicio simplemente va a seguir
corriendo hasta que se le termine el
piso
digamos que va corriendo sobre este
precipicio
con una velocidad inicial de 5 metros
por segundo
y va horizontalmente derechito hacia
afuera del precipicio y digamos que esto
es una locura porque este precipicio va
a tener 30 metros de altura
esa persona sale corriendo a una altura
de 30 metros y una velocidad de 5 metros
por segundo aquí abajo hay agua así que
esta persona inicialmente irá por aquí y
después va a ir cayendo cayendo cayendo
al agua
cae en el agua con una gran salpicadura
esperemos que no se lastimen al caer en
el agua y esperemos que no haya golpeado
ningún pececito que haya nadado por esa
zona
así que bueno nuestra persona cayó
directamente al agua y queremos saber
qué tan lejos llegó esa persona
horizontalmente antes de caer en el agua
este es un problema clásico
y si ustedes tienen experiencia en estos
lanzamientos al agua desde precipicios
que yo la verdad no los recomiendo si
ustedes no tienen la experiencia previa
si ustedes hacen esto profesionalmente
seguramente querrán saber qué tan lejos
llegan al saltar de un precipicio de
esta altura por ejemplo se pueden
preguntar qué tan rápido debo ir para
evitar estas piedras que se encuentran
por acá
aquí una costa medio pedregosa que
estaba muy finita y no queremos caer ahí
así que qué tan rápido debemos correr
para librar estas rocas y caer en el
agua conceptualmente lo que sucede aquí
es lo mismo que en cualquier problema de
lanzamiento de proyectiles
el desplazamiento horizontal se va a dar
de manera independiente del
desplazamiento vertical a lo que me
refiero es que la velocidad vertical
evoluciona de forma independiente de la
velocidad horizontal
digamos que la dirección vertical es
rosa y la dirección horizontal es verde
esta velocidad vertical va a estar
cambiando pero la velocidad horizontal
va a permanecer igual estas dos no se
influencian mutuamente en otras palabras
si esta velocidad horizontal inicio con
5 metros por segundo la persona siempre
va a tener 5 metros por segundo
en la dirección horizontal esta
dirección horizontal siempre va a ser de
5 metros por segundo y esto va a ser en
toda la caída suponiendo que la persona
es un proyectil que se encuentra en
caída libre esas personas no tienen algo
que los impulsen hacia adelante algún
cohete o algo así y aquí no hay
resistencia al aire esta persona siempre
tendrá una velocidad horizontal de 5
metros por segundo
hasta el momento en el que caiga el agua
en ese momento las fuerzas en el agua
van a influenciar esta velocidad pero no
vamos a considerar esto que pasa a
verticalmente pues verticalmente al
inicio esta persona no tendrá ninguna
velocidad esta persona corre
horizontalmente fuera del precipicio y
entonces comenzará a ganar velocidad
hacia abajo por lo que irá ganando
velocidad vertical conforme vaya bajando
va a ir aumentando su velocidad vertical
ya que la gravedad sigue jalándolo y va
a ser bastante grande justo en el
momento de tocar el agua aunque aquí en
mi pantalla no tengo el espacio
suficiente para dibujarlo
aquí sí ya tendremos una gran cantidad
de velocidad vertical ya que la gravedad
está influenciando en esta dirección
vertical pero no en la dirección
horizontal como calculamos esto vamos a
escribir lo que sabemos lo que sabemos
es que esta persona comenzó con una
velocidad horizontal de inicial en la
dirección x v0 en la dirección x que
significa velocidad inicial que es de 5
metros por segundo horizontalmente
no conocemos nada más en la dirección x
quizas digan bueno estos 30 metros son
el desplazamiento en la dirección
horizontal pero no estos 30 metros es el
desplazamiento en la dirección vertical
y no nos dicen nada de esta dirección
horizontal y lo que nos interesa es esta
distancia horizontal este desplazamiento
en la dirección x es lo que nos interesa
saber no sabemos cómo encontrarla pero
si sabemos que la queremos encontrar
qué sabemos de lo que sucede en la
dirección vertical ahora si podemos usar
estos 30 metros
podríamos decir que la diferencia en el
desplazamiento vertical o del taller es
igual a 30 30 positivo pero esto no es
correcto porque esta persona va cayendo
hacia abajo y va cayendo 30 metros hacia
abajo
comienza en la parte de arriba del
precipicio termina en la parte de abajo
por lo que esta persona va a terminar
por debajo de donde inicia 30 metros por
debajo de donde inicio así que esta
diferencia en el desplazamiento vertical
es de menos 30 metros suponiendo que
establecemos que todo lo que va hacia
abajo va a tener un signo negativo que
es la convención típica
hacia abajo es negativo y hacia la
izquierda también es negativo y si
ustedes eligen que hacia abajo es
negativo esta diferencia también va a
ser una distancia negativa que más
sabemos con respecto a la dirección
vertical pues sabemos que para cualquier
objeto en caída libre la aceleración
vertical siempre va a ser igual a menos
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
nuevamente suponiendo que hacia abajo es
negativo y en este punto es en donde
muchas personas se confunden
se equivocan pensando que la velocidad
inicial en la dirección vertical es de 5
metros por segundo pero no es así las
personas siempre quieren poner esta
velocidad aquí pues porque es la
velocidad que nos están dando pero esta
es una velocidad horizontal es por eso
que a esto le llamamos lanzamiento
horizontal de proyectil no es un
lanzamiento vertical de proyectil dense
cuenta que nuestra velocidad inicial
vertical aquí es de cero no hay una
velocidad vertical inicial
esta persona no brinco hacia arriba al
saltar ni salto hacia abajo al caer del
precipicio simplemente se lanzó
horizontalmente por lo que la velocidad
inicial en la dirección vertical es cero
y a las personas por alguna razón no les
gusta esto
pero realmente esta persona va a ir
ganando velocidad una vez que ya salió
del precipicio y esto va a ir aumentando
conforme vaya cayendo esto va a ser en
la dirección vertical pero después de
que dejamos el precipicio y la velocidad
inicial es en el momento justo en el que
apenas estamos dejando el precipicio en
ese momento sólo tenemos una velocidad
horizontal por lo que significa que
iniciamos con una velocidad vertical de
cero esto es una parte en la que muchos
se confunden porque no nos están
diciendo explícitamente en el problema
por lo general nunca nos van a decir
calcula la velocidad del proyectil
teniendo una velocidad vertical inicial
de cero
simplemente nos dicen que esa persona
tiene una velocidad horizontal en el
precipicio de cinco metros por segundo y
nos van a pedir encontrar esto y
nosotros tenemos que reducir que si
salimos corriendo horizontalmente de un
precipicio o cualquier cosa que sea
lanzada horizontalmente no va
tener velocidad inicial vertical por lo
que siempre nuestra velocidad inicial
vertical va a ser igual a cero así que
no se equivoquen en esto ahora que ya
conocen cuál es la razón queremos
encontrar el desplazamiento en la
dirección horizontal y cuántas variables
tenemos en la dirección vertical pues
todo esto lo conocemos pero no podemos
usar esto para calcular directamente
nuestra incógnita necesitamos usar esto
para encontrar el tiempo el tiempo va a
ser el mismo para la dirección
horizontal y para la dirección vertical
así que una vez que conozco el tiempo
puedo sustituir lo aquí para encontrar
mi desplazamiento pues el tiempo que
tardamos de saltar a caer pues va a ser
el mismo ya sea en la dirección
horizontal que en la dirección vertical
el tiempo va a ser el mismo para ambas
direcciones en otras palabras el tiempo
que me lleva el desplazamiento en esta
dirección vertical hacia abajo va a ser
el mismo tiempo que me lleva este
desplazamiento horizontal hacia la
derecha vamos a despejar el tiempo como
lo hacemos bueno conocemos el
desplazamiento y con
hacemos la aceleración también conocemos
la velocidad inicial y queremos conocer
el tiempo tomen en cuenta que no
conocemos la velocidad final y tampoco
nos están pidiendo encontrar una
velocidad final así que vamos a buscar
una fórmula en donde no tengamos la
velocidad final y ésta podría ser
nuestro desplazamiento vertical es igual
a la velocidad inicial vertical por el
tiempo más un medio de la aceleración
vertical por el tiempo al cuadrado ahora
podemos sustituir valores el
desplazamiento en la dirección vertical
es menos 30 mi velocidad inicial en la
dirección vertical es 0 y aquí es donde
ocurre el error aquí es donde las
personas normalmente tienen muchas ganas
de poner esta velocidad de acá pero no
lo hagan es una trampa cero por t es
igual a cero
aquí nos quedó un cero más un medio por
la aceleración vertical que es de menos
nueve punto ocho metros por segundo al
cuadrado por el tiempo al cuadrado
despejó a la t cuadrada y obtengo la
raíz cuadrada en ambos lados de la
igualdad multiplico ambos lados por 2 me
queda menos 30 metros por 2 y divido
ambos lados
entre menos 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado tengan en cuenta que si se les
olvida el signo negativo de acá cuando
lleguen a la raíz cuadrada aquí arriba
van a tener algo positivo y aquí abajo
algo negativo y aquí tendrían que
obtener la raíz cuadrada de un número
negativo y su calculadora les va a decir
oye no entiendo que quieres hacer y se
van a quedar chispas ya no sé qué hacer
y probablemente van a llegar a este
punto y se van a dar cuenta de que
pusieron mal el signo y bueno quizás
pongan aquí todo positivo para ver si
funciona y si si les va a funcionar
porque aquí estos dos negativos se van a
cancelar pero siempre es mejor saber qué
es lo que estamos haciendo y no estar
inventando que podríamos hacer así que
tengan cuidado con sus signos y todo
debe de salir bien si resolvemos esto
nos queda que el tiempo que nos llevo es
de 2.47 segundos qué
bastante tiempo a veces nos parece que
caemos durante mucho tiempo cuando
saltamos de una mesa o de un trampolín
normalmente eso nos lleva sólo una
fracción de segundo pero esto de 2.47
segundos es bastante tiempo para una
caída tomamos esto que es el tiempo que
nos llevó desplazarnos verticalmente en
este lanzamiento y con esto podremos
calcular cuál fue el desplazamiento
horizontal
podemos usar la misma fórmula podemos
decir que la diferencia en x es igual a
la velocidad inicial en la dirección x
es la misma fórmula pero ahora en la
dirección horizontal por el tiempo más
un medio por la aceleración horizontal
por el tiempo al cuadrado esa es también
la fórmula pero en la dirección x delta
x es de x ya le dimos un nombre así que
esto es de x esto es igual a mi
velocidad inicial horizontal que ahora
sí es de 5 metros por segundo
cuál es el tiempo pues el que acabamos
de encontrar 2 puntos 47 segundos
ese es el intervalo de tiempo el tiempo
que va desde que esta persona sale
corriendo del precipicio hasta que cae
al agua vamos a poner esto aquí arriba
es 2 punto 47 segundos y esto lo ponemos
por acá y que hay con esta a equis a
equis es cero ya que no hay nada que
haga que esta persona se acelere en la
dirección horizontal no tiene cohetes o
motores que lo estén empujando en esta
dirección no hay resistencia al aire por
lo que no hay ninguna razón para que se
acelere en esta dirección mantiene la
misma velocidad durante todo el trayecto
que obtenemos si despejamos de equis nos
queda que dx es 12.4 me parece así es
12.4 metros si estas rocas de aquí abajo
se extendieran más de 12 metros
entonces ya estaríamos en problemas
realmente no deberíamos hacer esto
y de hecho por seguridad nunca traten de
hacer esto en casa deje esto para estos
clavadistas profesionales y ustedes
fueran profesionales entonces tendrían
que calcular qué velocidad deben de
llevar antes de saltar para evitar caer
en estas rocas así que en resumen estos
son los errores más comunes que las
personas cometen en este tipo de
problemas asegúrense de que pongan su
signo negativo en el desplazamiento
vertical ya que van hacia abajo pero el
mayor error es que pongan otro valor en
la velocidad inicial vertical la
velocidad inicial vertical es cero
porque aquí sólo tenemos una velocidad
horizontal recuerden que esto no se les
va a dar explícitamente y ustedes tienen
que incluirlo por su cuenta gracias a
sus conocimientos sobre física